Israel has
carried out a
deadly military operation
in a crowded West Bank
refugee camp
targeting a suspect in the shooting death
of two Israeli settlers.
Israel says that man was killed along
with five other people.
An IDF
official tells CNN
soldiers surrounded the suspect's house
in Jenin,
came under
fire and responded with shoulder
fired missiles.
A spokesman
for the Palestinian Authority
president slammed
the use of missiles as an act of war.
Hamas says the target of the raid
was a member of the militant group
and had carried out
last week's attack on the Israeli
brothers in Hura.
Settlers went on a rampage
against Palestinians in Juarez
after that attack,
killing a civilian
and triggering and triggering,
I should say, international demands
for accountability.
Meanwhile, dozens of Israeli fighter
pilots are joining a growing revolt
within the military
against the government's
plans to weaken the judiciary.
They are threatening to boycott
training exercises tomorrow.
Mass Street protests have rocked Israel
for weeks with critics
warning
the judicial overhaul
would end democracy.
But the growing defiance
by some military members is adding
a new dimension,
really, to the movement,
deeply shaking the government.
Hundreds of reservists across
military branches are threatening
not to serve.
Yesterday, Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said they are endangering
Israel's existence.
Well, our next guest says it's clear
the reservists don't want to serve under,
quote, dictatorship
Dan Halutz is a retired
lieutenant general
in the Israeli Air Force.
He also served
as chief of staff of the IDF.
Dan, thank you very much
for taking the time
to speak to us here on the show.
Just explain to our viewers
watching from around the world,
what is it about these judicial reforms
that worry you?
They're forced you to come out
and speak out against them.
Well, I
wish it was a judicial reform.
It's not a reform
of the judicial revolution
and the meaning of revolution.
Is a
they are trying.
They buy it
by saying they
I refer to the prime minister
and these people,
they are trying to change the system,
the Israeli system from democracy,
liberal democracy, open free democracy
to a kind of
dictatorship.
We don't know what kind
but is subject to the if all the rules
and all the legislation
will be confirmed.
Right now
we have the first stage
and we still have to pass
through other stages
in order to confirm it and to approve it.
And the meaning is
that they want to weaken
the Supreme Court, mainly
because the Supreme Court
is a kind of obstacle to all
the coalition,
the coalition
members, the parties of the coalition.
And the we we are deploying
that the
all the participants in the coalition
had the same interest
to weaken the Supreme Court.
Prime Minister
Netanyahu is trying to escape
from his three accused
and in criminal in criminal
indictments and the last for a second.
We have a convicted
member
of the parliament who want to renominated
as a minister
after the Supreme Court
rejected him from his nomination
There we have the
ultra orthodox
parties
that are looking for way
to escape
from serving the country in the military.
And they want to
just to continue to learn their Torah
and infos. Is Mr.
Smart Rich, the minister of Treasury
and his partner
Ben-gvir,
who is the internal security minister,
both of them in the past.
The second was convicted in the accused
and found guilty in 88 actions
of so-called terrorism
against the Palestinians, mainly
and the other one was
almost in the same process,
but never accused.
Let me let me get you mentioned Smotrich.
You mentioned Smotrich.
Let me jump in here,
because obviously we brought that story
to all viewers
when we heard the comments
from the finance minister, Bezalel
Smotrich, saying the
the Palestinian town of Hura,
he said, needs to be erased.
When you heard that
those pilots, of course,
that we are talking about,
they'll probably be protesting tomorrow.
What, not showing up tomorrow?
How would they interpret that?
How would they interpret
an order like that?
Is this what worries you
Absolutely.
Because those pilots, by the way,
they are not refusing to serve.
They say a simple thing,
if the system will be changed
from democracy to dictatorship,
they are not
obliged to serve under the dictators.
That's all.
And they will take the necessary step
according to their values.
And their values are the highest values
And when they heard Smotrich,
they mentioned it, by the way,
when they addressed to their commanders,
they said that they are afraid
that such an orders
will be given to them in the future
and they are not ready to accomplish
they are not ready to be part of it.
That's the reason
and slot, which is an ultra extremist.
He has a vision to do.
He's against a two state solution
for example,
he wants one
state from the Jordan in the sea
and about the Palestinian.
He has his own solutions
that I don't want to repeat.
Let me you know,
one of the concerns, of course, is that
this could open them up
to prosecution
of these pilots, up to prosecution
from the International Criminal Court.
But I want to get your reaction.
First of all,
let me get your reaction to what we heard
from Prime Minister
Netanyahu and Ben-gvir,
I should add, as well,
who who call the protesters
that we have seen
for the last several what I say
last week or two or so,
they're calling them anarchists.
Are you
and the
and the pilots
who are refusing to train here,
are you an anarchist on
that one?
They say, you know, an anarchist,
convicted anarchist
is calling me anarchists.
He never served in the military, never
you never hold a gun in your head.
You never smell the battlefield.
And he's calling us those of both
for Israel for the last 75 years.
I a you know,
the cynical way of politician
of a very bad politician
to address the people and the same
the same
the same thing
I'm saying about our prime minister
you know they all play
they're playing politics with values
and values are not subjected
to any politics They are pure values.
You know,
we are proud
of sharing common values with us.
Unfortunately, I'm saying that we
are diverting from from that.